you
consider any triangle and let's call it
triangle ABC we know what the internal
angles are but what are exterior angles
of a triangle it's simple we just extend
any one side let us produce side BC to
point D like this since we've just
extended BC to D it means that BD is
also a straight line that's it this
angle is an exterior angle angle ACD is
in the exterior of the triangle which is
why it's called the exterior angle we
know that these three angles are
interior but this time we will look at
them with respect to their exterior
angle first let's look at this angle
angle ACB we know that it lies in the
interior of the triangle and it is
adjacent to this exterior angle so with
respect to this exterior angle angle ACB
is the interior adjacent angle what
about the other two angles angle ABC and
angle BAC they too are both in the
interior region of the triangle but they
are not adjacent to the exterior angle
they are called as interior opposite
angles let's try to derive an
interesting relation between the
exterior and the interior opposite
angles let's erase this
and form a new triangle let's call it
ABC and we extend side BC to point D for
convenience let us name the interior
angles one two and three and the
exterior one as four we know that the
sum of interior angles of the triangle
is 180 degrees the sum of interior
angles is angle one plus angle two plus
angle three this sum should equal 180
degrees and can you guess the sum of
angle 3 and this exterior angle what
would measure of angle 3 plus the
measure of angle 4 be equal to if you
notice the figure carefully you will see
that they form a straight line yes they
form a linear pair the sum would equal
180 degrees both these expressions equal
180 degrees it means they have to be
equal we can say that angle 1 plus angle
2 plus angle 3 is equal to angle 3 plus
angle 4 subtracting the measure of angle
3 from both the sides we can say that
angle 1 plus angle 2 is equal to angle 4
if you noticed angle 4 is the exterior
angle and angles 1 and 2 are the
interior opposite angles this proves
that the exterior angle of any triangle
is always equal to the sum of its
interior opposite angles